I'm on my way to Curtis house is
Connecticut's oldest then I'm excited
about it because it's supposed to be one
of New England's historical gems there's
nothing wrong with being the oldest just
depends how much Botox you've had I'm
going to be arriving on a big day for
hotels and restaurants across America
but there's something I've got to do
first
[Music]
I'm viral thank you I'm just bringing
you to wish you happy Mother's Day
well I'm sorry I can't be with you let's
have a great day
love you lots ah great
here we are the Curtis house kinetic is
always in lovely the happy Mother's Day
sign looks a bit crap I suppose is the
thought that counts
bill before 1736 incredible dawn I see
well welcome to the Curtis house happy
Mother's Day thank you very much I'm
Melissa first name babe I know you're a
baby what's your name Shirley Shirley
nice seam I die
so it's Mother's Day Russians but yes is
the hotel for not tonight
Oh how many movies are books just one
just one yeah just me yes
so I'm a little bit early okay usually
checking is three o'clock trick knows
usually a $10 an hour feet
that's what for our so $40 already yes
so I could save a little bit of money by
hanging out and I actually got into the
room yes so I want to say myself 40
bucks
yes so if I just take a little nap what
is he doing mr. Ramsey that's really not
appropriate mr. Ramsey Gordon I'm sorry
but it doesn't make sense you charge me
$10 an hour if I just hang out on the
sofa get a little blanket like save
myself some money you know this rule
actually went into effect about six
months ago this $10 an hour everything
and is it making a big impact on the
business people don't like it the
bookings in the rooms have definitely
gone downhill I think they would be a
lot busier TJ didn't have these
ridiculous rules um is that right my
details in here credit-card details yes
we take a credit card number to hold the
room I appreciate that but why put in
the book that's the house Palestine if
the customer insist then we can't erase
it once they check in I got the credit
card details everybody I will have to
call nine-one-one I don't really have to
call nine-one-one do I babe see by the
time you called 911 one okay
I've hacked into every credit card in
this book and made myself a fortune so
whose policies this a bit with this is
our policy like GG later the owner yes
would you not think there's a security
breach there that's what her policy is
no one to look in this book except the
desk person well okay I can't believe
you're gonna be in room 16 why cuz room
16 has a ghost in it
this woman told me who went to room 16
she said the ghost was pulling the
blankets off her all night long and you
haven't been drinking sherry Wow Betty
years ago set the Curtis house and
people do tell us fast she raises a
little bit of havoc with him
she's definitely there room 16 the
haunted room my goodness me where's the
helmet footprint no was a little big
stuff yes it looks like a footprint to
me almost I'm dead bugs oh dear
Oh chase Brewers well here I give know a
list of the rooms that are coming in
they're supposed to throw a check the
room that was week two week three have
electricity Nelson
I couldn't believe our Borden found in
that room and what is this
nobody just realized took air how are
you working here I've been on since
about 1965 how was it then busy all the
time
48 years that's incredible so this place
means a lot to you oh yes my second home
are you connected to the family in any
way
TJ's parents and my mother were cousins
so must be sad for you to see it
certainly yes definitely and why is it
struggling that's the way our two bosses
get along I was it different when TJ and
Krista's parents were running it oh yeah
much more professional so why do you
stay huh why'd you put up with this I
take pride in this place I like this
place I can see that I really do but
they don't understand that the place is
brilliant word there
I really think TJ and Chris are really
hurt in the business somebody needs to
knock some sense into them first
impressions
there's no all my credit card details
downstairs in that book in such a
vulnerable position one of the busiest
weekend's ever first hotel there
Mother's Day and the only ones staying
in the hotel that's that's not good dust
everywhere a windowsill full of bugs I
don't think I'm gonna get possessed a
yeah
your disease right downstairs have a
look hey let me out honestly it must be
the bloody ghost come on Betty let me
out I just want to get some lunch